the protagonist of the movie is a
23-year-old woman named Noah who is
desperate to get a boyfriend she uses
online dating sites and has gone out
with several men but all of them have
resulted in disappointment during one
such date she meets a man named Chadwick
who turns out to be a complete idiot he
only makes misogynistic remarks and
talks about his money he also makes it
clear that Noah will be paying for their
dinner as their conversation unfolds
Noah becomes increasingly annoyed and
she decides to leave but shadwick makes
sure to pass some mean remarks on her he
calls her a let down who wasted his
precious time Noah who isn't used to
such a disappointment doesn't say a word
and simply leaves later at the gym she
confides in her best friend Molly about
the incident she believes that she is
going to remain single her entire life
however Molly assures her God is saving
the best man for her that would mean
that God is keeping a bunch of dudes
chained up somewhere at night Noah goes
to a nearby supermarket where she bumps
into a man named Steve the two quickly
Bond over their shared love for cotton
candy grapes and Noah appears to be
Smitten by his charm before they go
their separate ways Steve abruptly asks
for her number being the desperate girl
that she is Noah gives it to him without
any hesitation the following day she
talks about Steve with her best friend
Molly Noah mentions that he's a handsome
guy with a good personality but the sad
thing is that he hasn't texted her yet
in response Molly jokes that he's
probably married later as Noah is on her
way home she finally gets a call from
Steve he wastes no time and asks her out
on a date Noah is taken aback by the
sudden Quest but she is so desperate
that she agrees without thinking much
she's seen Pam and Tommy she knows this
guy has a huge wiener during their date
Steve and Noah open up and share about
their backgrounds he reveals that he's
actually a surgeon from Texas and is new
to this town in turn Noah says that she
just graduated from college and is
looking for a job the two then cona over
the fact that they don't have parents
and are living alone Steve also mentions
that he's so focused with his work that
he doesn't have time to use any social
media after their date Noah asks him to
come over to his apartment there things
get heated and the two end up having a
romantic time the next morning Noah
wakes up feeling refreshed this is the
happiest she has been in a long while
she secretly takes a photo of a sleeping
Steve and then calls her best friend
Molly to share the details of her
fantastic night you should have seen the
wiener Molly is happy for her but thinks
it's strange that Steve isn't on the
internet as their conversation unfolds
NOA mentions that Molly's ex-boyfriend
Paul was working as a bartender at the
restaurant last night it is revealed
that mly recently came out as a lesbian
and broke up with Paul the following
night Noah meets up with her new
boyfriend again while having some
takeout they discuss more about their
lives Noah shares that she has a best
friend named Molly who knows everything
about her after the two finish eating
Steve suggests they dance Noah is a bit
unsure but ends up having a lot of fun
they eventually get tired and sit down
out of the blue Steve then asks Noah if
she'd like to go on a weekend trip with
him she asks about the destination but
he keeps it a secret because what fun
would it be if he didn't raise every red
flag possible nonetheless she agrees as
she has started to really like him after
Steve departs Noah calls her best friend
and tells her about the upcoming trip
Molly is a bit worried as Noah is going
out with someone she barely knows
however the latter reassures her best
friend that she will be fine she also
sends a picture of Steve to her saying
he is perfect the following day Steve
takes Noah to his place saying they will
be leaving for the trip early the next
morning our girl innocently agrees but
she still has no idea what's in store
for her she tries to text Molly about
her location but her phone's signal
appears to be weak after driving for
several hours they finally arrive at a
shady looking house it appears to be
completely isolated from the rest of the
city Noah is a bit weirded out by this
but she doesn't say anything for the
moment after a while Steve prepares a
drink and gives it to her he asks her to
guess its contents but as soon as Noah
tastes it she feels dizzy and passes out
after regaining Consciousness she finds
herself chained up in a room with Steve
he confesses to drugging her which
leaves Noah feeling confused and scared
Steve then drops a major bombshell he is
actually a cannibal who eats human meat
and also sells it to wealthy clients he
explains that many of his clients prefer
the meat of young women so he tricks and
kidnaps them by taking them on dates he
also tells Noah that he plans to keep
her alive for as long as possible to
maintain the freshness of her flesh
while removing the body parts slowly
Terri for her life Noah tries to fight
back but Steve overpowers her and pins
her to the ground after the cannibal
leaves Noah desperately calls for help a
woman from the adjacent room named Penny
answers back revealing that Steve has
kidnapped several women here as the two
women talk to each other they learn that
both of them are orphans this means that
Steve only targets women with no parents
as he knows that no one will come
looking for them just then another woman
starts singing and Penny reveals that
it's Steve's other victim named Melissa
who has lost her mother mind after being
kidnapped on the other hand Molly begins
to worry after not hearing from her
friend for a while she sends her a few
messages and surprisingly Steve texts
her back using Noah's phone he mentions
that they are relaxing at a cottage far
away from the city he also sends her an
image of a beautiful waterfall and says
that Noah is planning to switch off her
mobile phone for a while she is doing so
to get away from technology and enjoy
nature Molly who knows her best friend
pretty well senses that something is a
mess people don't say they like
like that unless they're trying to
invent a fake version of themselves for
dating apps so she looks up the
waterfall image on the internet to find
its location lo and behold it turns out
to be a stock photo taken from a random
website on the other hand Steve
approaches Noah again but this time he
is gentle he hands her some new clothes
and even lets her take a shower Noah
takes advantage of this kindness and
tries to run away but unfortunately
Steve manages to capture her he then
drags her to the surgery room and
removes her butth Hawks as punishment I
can't help it I'm a fan of the buttock
says Steve elsewhere Molly starts
looking for her best friend at first she
goes to her ex-boyfriend Paul's
restaurant where Noah had her first date
with Steve the two awkwardly greet each
other and Molly Gets straight to the
point she inquires with Paul if he knows
about this Steve guy the bartender
appears to be a bit hesitant as he is
not allowed to share client details but
with Molly insisting he has no choice
but to comply Paul then reveals that the
guy's actual name is Brendan Camp later
Molly returns home and searches the on
the internet she learns that he is
married to a woman named Anne and has
two children after this Molly decides to
pay Anne a visit she also sends the
location to Paul asking him to come
looking for her if anything goes wrong
back at the Butcher House Noah learns
that she is the only victim Steve has
slept with this means that he might have
a soft spot for her Noah then decides to
take advantage of this situation from
that moment onwards she stops resisting
and tries to seduce Steve every chance
she gets she also shows a sudden
interest in human meat saying she wants
to taste it in the next scene Molly
reaches anan's location and straightway
reveals that her husband has been dating
other women the woman appears to be
startled by this Revelation so she
invites Molly inside for a chat
unfortunately as they delve further into
their conversation Steve suddenly shows
up he acts cool and pretends that he
doesn't know anyone by the name of Noah
this somewhat convinces Molly and she
believes that she is barged into the
wrong house but before she leaves she
gives her friend another call call to
her surprise the phone rings in Steve's
pocket revealing that he is actually the
kidnapper why would he have her phone
though now that he has been exposed
Steve cunningly says that she shouldn't
have come in here Molly tries to run
away but before she can do so Anna
knocks her out from behind it turns out
that she is also a cannibal friend of
Steve and they probably have little
cannibal babies too sometime later Steve
moves Molly to his remote Butcher House
in the woods then he goes back to Noah
gives her new clothes and invites
invites her for dinner in another scene
we see Anne in the bathroom revealing
that she has a fake leg this suggests
that she was once one of Steve's victims
before becoming his wife during dinner
Steve and Noah have a heart-to-heart
conversation almost as if they're a
couple she inquires how he got into this
business to which he shares that he
tasted human meat for the first time
when he was 18 initially he was scared
of being caught by the police but then
he couldn't get enough of that taste as
the years passed he developed a craving
for human meat and made friends shared
his unusual taste eventually he found a
community willing to pay a lot of money
for this rare meat it's amazing what you
can find on Facebook these days turning
him into a human meat trafficker after
sharing his story Steve offers Noah some
human flesh she is disgusted by it but
to keep up her facade she eats it with a
happy face after dinner Steve takes
Molly away for his gruesome purposes
meanwhile Paul not having heard from his
ex-girlfriend for a while gets worried
and starts searching for for her cut to
the next scene Steve invites Noah for
another dinner she seems to have gained
his trust by now which becomes even more
evident when he gives her a lovely pink
dress later during dinner as Noah
munches on some human flesh Steve
reveals that it is Melissa this
expectedly horrifies our girl but she
doesn't allow it to show on her face
after dinner Steve shows her a hidden
space filled with items from his victims
indicating that he's abducted and killed
many women before he then discloses
something disgusting his clients
actually like to have the belongings of
the women they eat which makes them feel
closer to their food just then Noah
spots Molly's phone in the corner this
makes her realize that her best friend
had come looking for her but ended up
becoming another one of his victims
Furious Noah decides to take action
right now she knows that Steve can
change his demeanor any day so she has
to act quickly hence she gathers up the
courage and asks him for a dance
surprisingly he agrees and even uncuff
her after setting the mood with a
romantic dance she leaves leads him to
his room on the pretense of pleasuring
him however instead of giving him a good
time she brutally bites off his ball
sack Noah then hurriedly grabs the keys
and runs away while Steve continues
writhing in pain she soon reaches the
compartment where the other victims are
being held all of them appear to be dead
except for Penny and her best friend
Molly Noah quickly frees them and the
trio proceeds to escape but out of
nowhere a nutless Steve shows up and
attacks them a tense battle then ensues
between the two parties and despite
Steve being outnumbered and injured he
manages to overpower the women however
he soon becomes tired and gets knocked
out the girls then grab Molly's phone
and escape the place but they aren't
able to reach very far as Penny appears
to be missing a limb unfortunately Steve
once again shows up this time with a gun
in hand he fires several rounds at them
but each of them Miss meanwhile Paul has
arrived outside the house just in time
to die probably following the GPS on
Molly's phone when he hears the gunshots
he immediately makes a run for it
probably for the best Paul the girls
noticed this and realized that help
isn't arriving anytime soon so they
decide to take matters into their own
hands they quickly form a plan and split
up in separate directions to confuse the
unic cannibal and when Steve lunges at
one of them all three girls gang up and
beat him to a pulp Noah then grabs his
own gun and finishes him off after this
they try to call for help using Molly's
phone but it abruptly gets switched off
after a while Anne also arrives at the
place looking for her husband she finds
his lifeless body on the ground she gets
enraged and attacks Noah the two women
then go back and forth at each other and
it appears as if an is gaining the upper
hand but fortunately Molly arrives in
the nick of time and smashes the woman's
head in with a shovel she does this
repeatedly until Anne finally passes
away in the final scene as Molly and
Noah are trying to make sense of what
happened the ladder receives a text from
Chadwick he asks her you up subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching